نتنياهو يدعو لتحقيق مشترك مع مصر حول
حادث الحدود اجتماع سريه لاكبر 20 جهازا
استخباراتيا في العالم
السلطات الهنديه تحدد سبب ماساه القطارات
هذه الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها لكم من قناه
العربيه فاهلا بكم
في وقت لم تتكشف بشكل كامل بعد ملابسات
الحادث الحدوديه بين مصر واسرائيل دعا
رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو
الى اجراء تحقيق مشترك وشامل مع مصر حول
الحادث الذي وقع امسب وقتل على اثره ثلاثه
جنود اسرائيليين وعنصر امن مصري نتنياهو
قال لمجلس الوزراء انه بعث برساله واضحه
للحكومه المصريه وانه يتوقع ان يكون
التحقيق المشترك شاملا ومفصلا مضيفا ان
حكومته ستحدث الاجراءات الراميه للحد من
عمليات التهريب الى الحد الادنى ولضمان
عدم تكرار مثل هذه الهجمات مستقبلا
الى سنغافوره حيث افادت وكاله رويترز بان
مسؤولين كبارا من نحو 20 من اجهزه
الاستخبارات الكبرى في العالم عقدوا
اجتماعا سريا على هامش اجتماعات حوار
شانجريلا الامني مطلع هذا الاسبوع وبحسب
الوكاله فان هذه الاجتماعات التي لم يتم
الكشف عنها مسبقا تنظمها حكومه سنغافوره
وتعقد سرا في مكان منفصل الى جانب القمه
الامنيه منذ عده سنوات مديره الاستخبارات
الوطنيه الامريكيه شاركت في الاجتماع
السري في حين كانت الصين من بين الدول
الحاضره على الرغم من حاله التوتر بين
القوتين الكبيرتين
بعد كارثه القطار الماساويه التي اودت
بحياه اكثر من
288 شخصا واصابت 900 اخرين كشفت سلطات
الهنديه عن سبب وقوع الحاجه الهند قالت ان
تغييرا في المسارات حدث خلال التشابك
الالكتروني ما ادى الى وقوع الحادث في
اشاره الى نظام اشارات معقد مصمم لمنع
القطارات من الاصطدام عبر تنظيم حركتها
على القضبان فيما قال وزير السكك الحديد
في البلاد انه سيتم العثور على المسؤول عن
تلك الكارثه التي تعتبر من اسوا كوارث
القطارات في تاريخ الهند والعالم
في خبر سار لمرضى السكري تمكن علماء
امريكيون من اختراق الخلايا البشريه التي
تنتج ماده الانسولين وتوصلوا بفضل ذلك الى
عكس مرض السكري لدى الفئران وفق دراسه
حديثه نشرت في مجله
الدراسه تقوم على اعاده توظيف خلايا
المعده البشريه لاطلاق الانسولين ما مكن
من
اداره مرض السكري من النوع الاول والسيطره
عليه بشكل فعال حيث تموت عاده الخلايا
التي تنتج هرمون الانسولين لدى المصابين
فيما يامل العلماء بان يساعد البحث في دفع
الجسم الى انتاج الانسولين بشكل طبيعي مره
اخرى لاولئك المرضى
بينما كانت تتمشى على الشاطئ في
كاليفورنيا عثرت امراه امريكيه على شيء
غير اعتيادي في وسط الرمال ليتبين لاحقا
انه سن من حيوان الماستودون المنقرض
المراه التقطت صورا للسن الذي وجدته
ونشرتها عبر فيسبوك للاستفسار عن طبيعته
لياتي الجواب سريعا من
مستشار مجموعات علم الحفريات لمتحف
سانتاكروز للتاريخ الطبيعي والذي فاجاها
بان هذا الجسم هو درس باليه للماستودون
المنقرض منذ نحو 11 الف عام فيما بلغ طول
السن الذي وجدته السيده نحو 30 سم
[موسيقى]